welcome to max tech and this is our
review of the iPhone 11 pro in this
review I'm not gonna tell you that the
iPhone 11 pro is the best iPhone ever
made it obviously is I'm also not gonna
bore you with all the specs that you've
heard a thousand times already what I'm
gonna talk about are the things that
actually matter to both attack
enthusiasts like myself and an average
consumer like my wife both of us have
been using the iPhone 11 pro for a few
days now so I've collected my own
thoughts and I also interviewed my wife
to see what differences she noticed in
what she liked about her iPhone 11 Pro
but before I get into that let's first
talk about what happened at Apple's
event there's no doubt that a lot of
people were disappointed they argue that
Apple shouldn't have used the name Pro
since it's missing a few Pro features
like 120 Hertz refresh rate a USB C port
in reverse wireless charging but after
people started to get their hands on the
iPhone 11 Pro the disappointment started
to fade away so the question is does it
matter that the new iPhone is missing a
few Pro features that Apple fans were
anticipating well for most people not
really what it does pack is a few very
important features and changes that make
it a seriously good package overall in
terms of being a premium smartphone it
now packs all three camera lenses that
you'd hope to see in a smartphone
including a new night mode feature which
as you'll see later works incredibly
well it packs the best processor in any
smartphone
it has top-of-the-line battery life a
high quality display that's even
brighter this year incredibly balanced
speakers and it finally comes with a
fast charger in the box it packs
top-of-the-line security and it features
a truly unique design that you'll never
confuse for anything else it seems as
though for the first time in a very long
time the iPhone 11 pro gives you a
complete package of features and that's
what truly matters
[Music]
when it comes to upgrading your iPhone I
thought of a formula for iPhones
upgradability that is more realistic for
regular consumers and offering a full
package of features that work very well
together is the first piece of the
puzzle
second the iPhone has to look and feel
different not that many people upgraded
from the iPhone 10 to the 10s and that's
because it looked basically identical to
the 10 only the tennis max look
different because it was obviously much
larger and that's actually the flagship
model that most people upgraded to this
year the iPhone 11 probe looks and feels
way different with a brand new unique
feeling matte glass back a relocated
Apple logo the new popular midnight
green color and most importantly a very
unique square camera bump with large
triple camera lenses that really stand
out that new square bump with three
lenses has become a trademark alongside
the pro branding so now it's almost
impossible to mistake the 11pro for the
iPhone 10 or 10s unless you're looking
at the front of course the third thing
that matters is that it sounds different
and having the word Pro in the name is
more unique than ever before when I was
standing in line at the Apple store on
launch day I kept hearing regular people
saying that they want the new iPhone Pro
they seemed like they didn't really know
that much about tech but what they did
know is that they wanted the pro model
and throughout the weekend I kept
hearing people ask is that the new Pro
is that the iPhone Pro it seems as
though the 11-part of the name has faded
away under the success of the pro name
so it seems like using pro is already
working for apples benefit even if some
people disagree with it before I get
into my personal thoughts on what truly
matters about the iPhone 11 Pro and Pro
Macs as well as the downsides or
disappointments of the pro I want to
quickly mention the real-world
differences and changes my wife noticed
and enjoyed about her new 11 pro first
off she loves the camera especially the
new wider angle on the selfie cam
allowing her to fit more into the frame
without having to stretch her hand out
as far as she can she also absolutely
the new ultra wide lens and she had a
blast taking unique and creative photos
at the park she was also really
impressed with the video stabilization
and she actually really likes the square
bump on the back
compared to her old tennis Max's
vertical bump and she noticed much
better battery life as well in terms of
performance she didn't really notice the
difference coming from the 10s but she
doesn't really do any heavy tasks like
gaming or using professional apps or
anything like that so overall she's very
happy with their new iPhone 11 pro even
coming from the 10s so I think regular
consumers who are coming from an older
iPhone will definitely notice a
difference now let's get into the
real-world differences that I a tech
enthusiast noticed after spending a few
days with the iPhone 11 pro max first of
all I'm pleasantly surprised with the
battery life every time I check it I'd
be surprised at how high it was compared
to my old tennis max and on Sunday I was
at 61% battery life after coming home at
9:30 p.m. this has never happened on my
tennis max so I think the battery life
is perhaps the biggest deal on the new
iPhone 11 Pro and don't take my word for
it mister who's the boss just released
his battery drain test and even the
smaller iPhone 11 Pro beat out the note
10 plus and that was with the note
manually set to a lower resolution than
both of the iPhones at 1080p instead of
the 1440p the note is capable of and the
iPhone 11 pro max lasted 8 hours and 32
minutes the best battery life mister
who's the boss has ever seen on any
smartphone as far as the design I
seriously can't get enough of it the
matte finish on the glass feels
incredible in the hand and I'm shocked
at how Apple is able to pull off the
square bump on the back it just looks so
unique in premium compared to the
vertical bump on the 10s and so far
everyone else I know loves the new look
the speakers have also been improved
from the 10s max with the top and bottom
speakers being much more balanced than
before which is why I think the new
spatial audio sound effect works so well
as far as performance I honestly haven't
noticed a difference in the UI and using
the phone normally but what most people
don't really think about is that the
reason the cameras are as good as they
are is solely because of the extra
performance of the
13 Bionic chip in the 11pro that's where
most of the improvements are going and
I'll talk about them in just a minute
and even though a lot of the
improvements are geared towards
efficiency for getting that awesome
battery life we actually saw a huge
improvement in raw performance in both
processor and graphics workloads for
gaming the iPhone 10s had excellent
performance being able to max out the
graphics on basically any game we tried
but it had a huge issue while playing
fortnight at high brightness at 60
frames per second after only 10 minutes
the 10s would heat up and the display
would greatly dim so I tried it on the
11pro max and it was able to last much
longer before dimming and it didn't dim
nearly as much as before so I'm really
impressed with the efficiency of the new
a 13 chip
especially since you'll get better
battery life during long gaming sessions
in my opinion even if you can't notice
the difference in performance right now
having the extra power of the a 13 chip
for the next couple of years is going to
be a big deal from when new apps and
games come out that'll actually be able
to use that performance and now let's
get into the cameras the main upgrade
this year we now get the ultra wide lens
which is actually really fun to use the
quality isn't nearly as good as the wide
lens but it's a blast to get unique
angles and shots the wide lens looks
better than ever with excellent dynamic
range and image quality and I'm glad the
Apple added a bit more contrast to the
photos so they don't look as flat as
last year's 10s and the white balance
looks very consistent between lenses
whereas last year it leaned towards the
warm side far too often and for the
telephoto lens I've actually noticed
that photos taken with this lens turned
out better with less noise especially
for portrait mode photos however I'm
quite disappointed with portrait blur
edging I thought they did improve on
this this year but it still sucks when
it comes to missing large sections of
the background so I really hope Apple
adds a time-of-flight sensor next year
perhaps the biggest deal is Apple moving
from 7 megapixels to 12 on the
front-facing camera as well as making
the lens wider in general it's much more
detailed than before and being able to
record 4k 60fps selfie video is insane
and finally Apple has added a night mode
and it does such a great job as
actually since the colors turn out
natural and not oversaturated like on a
lot of other Android phones the only
downside is that you can't use night
mode with the ultra wide lens or the
selfie camera which is a huge bummer as
for video recording Apple has completely
knocked it out of the park with the
11pro the quality looks incredible and
beats out basically every other phone on
the market and this year the
stabilization is absolutely phenomenal
it just works so incredibly well in
Aleppo you can also record with the
ultra wide lens but the biggest
improvement for video recording comes
thanks to the a13 Bionic chip you can
now shoot at 4k 60 while getting
extended dynamic range which means that
the chip is actually recording 4k 120
with 60 darker frames and 60 brighter
frames being blended together in real
time to offer incredible dynamic range
this is a huge deal and it puts an even
bigger gap between it and other
smartphones however there's also a
really big downside with recording while
shooting in 4k 60 you can't switch
between lenses that means if you start
recording with the ultra wide lens you
can't zoom out or switch to another lens
it works perfectly fine while recording
at 30fps but not at 60 that's a major
flaw especially now that we have the
added ultra wide lens but overall the
cameras are outstanding on the 11pro and
we'll be putting out some very detailed
camera comparison shortly so if you're
not already subscribed make sure to do
that right now so you don't miss out on
those videos so that leads me into a few
things that I found extremely
disappointing this year yes the 11pro
offers the most complete
iPhone package we've seen in years and I
honestly think that most people who are
on the edge of upgrading should just do
it unless they're perfectly happy with
their current device but if we had these
three things I honestly think it would
be perfect
first off the same 4 gigabytes of RAM on
the 11pro
that's just a bit sad and even worse the
same 64 gigabytes of storage at the base
price is just embarrassing especially
since the note 10 plus comes with 256
gigabytes of even faster storage at the
same base price and finally I was really
hoping for an always-on display on the
11pro as
actually since Apple added it to their
new series five Apple watch but we still
don't have it on the iPhone other than
that the iPhone 11 Pro is an excellent
package overall and it looks and feels
more premium than ever before making the
$1000 price honestly seem worth it again
just like it was with the iPhone 10 from
two years ago this has been vadim with
max TAC and if you enjoyed this review
make sure to check out some of our other
videos right over there and click that
circle above to subscribe so you don't
miss out on our upcoming camera
comparisons thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one
[Music]